I use this one sure just saves me 10
seconds uh hi welcome everyone my name
is wenar guruswami I'm a senior
scientist here at the Simons Institute
and I'm also co-organizing a program on
error correcting codes theory and
practice uh next semester and I have a
great team of Co organizers uh Mary
woters at Stanford Henry Fister at Duke
shakan Gopi at Microsoft research and
Jill zore uh from University of bordo
and um this is going to happen along a
program on Quantum fall tolerance which
is a really uh great opportunity because
Quantum eror correcting codes are a
really burning and important topic now
so I don't have slides but briefly what
are error correcting codes we all you
know know and use them they protect data
from noise it's a classical field which
uh originated in information Theory
electrical engineering but now cross
Cuts uh W computer science math and uh
physics and of course is hugely uh
relevant uh in practice of you know
whenever we store or communicate data or
you you know soon when we'll be doing
quantum computers so there's been and
again along the side the goals of the
Simon institute there's been flurry of
progress along all these axes we have
now algebraic codes which get to
capacity in worst case and random models
we have very interesting progress on
local decodability of codes polar codes
are amazing and already in 5G within 15
years of Discovery a lot of progress on
the mathy aspects of coding Theory and
breakthroughs on Quantum ldpc codes
which are also very exciting and as I
mentioned on the Practical side polar
codes are in 5G uh locally repairable
codes make have made it big in um data
centers and cloud storage and heavily in
use every day and Quantum codes are
really knocking on the door and will
hopefully make large scale Quantum
Computing reality so these the program
is really catalyzed by these rich
developments and brings together a wide
variety of researchers from CS math um
and W and also industry uh partners and
I want to you know especially for this
audience talk about the Synergy with uh
practice uh error correcting codes is a
really unique field in the sense that
new technologies give rise to new
theoretical problems which we can study
and some of these are really fundamental
and these Solutions then feed back to uh
practice and there are many examples of
this and uh and so that's what makes
this feel very unique so I we really
welcome and look forward to lots of
connections with um industry in the next
semester and with this in mind for
example one of the workshops I didn't
talk about the workshops but one of the
workshops um all the programs have three
workshops and a boot camp and one of the
workshops is actually going to be
earmarked for application driven coding
Theory and our hope is that also to take
advantage of the fact that we are in
Silicon Valley and there are lots of
companies interested in novel
Technologies to process and uh data
reliably to get new kinds of problems
where we can really collaborate and
there might be other fora like specific
uh brainstorming industry days also
which we might plan so that's in
planning and the other Synergy I want to
to mention is with the quantum program
in in Quantum Computing in some sense
the era correction is really the burning
question and these stumbling BL block to
make scalable Quantum Computing possible
and there's lots of exciting
developments on that so we will have a
joint workshop with the other program to
really you know increase the Synergy and
also have the boot camp will be joined
as well so that said I'm really looking
forward to an exciting uh semester of uh
research Discovery and hopefully a lot
of impact and Synergy with
practice
[Applause]